if you like crawling climbing and
jumping into cold water then these
endurance events might just be for you
they're growing in popularity in Germany
here at the X let exchange almost 4,000
amateur athletes will push themselves to
the limit this group from ma blog are
among those taking part for some of them
it's the first time at an event like
this speed it's about having fun as a
group it's not about our tiny side
phenom it was on my bucket list I have
to try it on East once you know my
gramma tumbles ensued to reach the
finish line and to have fun with the
team those are my main motivations
strength this is study motivates you own
a specimen the group all want to finish
the race together
but it'll be a challenge for every
member of the team as these events
become more popular organizers are
coming up with new races to meet the
demand this year there are more than 70
with eight of those set up by the
organizer X let Ock's the obstacles pose
a huge challenge for many participants
it's great I just fell in the water but
otherwise it's great i'm here with
people from work and now i'm exhausted i
feel good but we've only done four
kilometers there are still tend to go to
go ok much 25 obstacles placed over 13
kilometers forced the competitors to get
their hands and everything else dirty
sports psychologist tomas Hybels as
events like these are popular because
they contrast with the comfort of modern
life
Izumo provided by trying to get back in
touch with ourselves by doing these
races leben we want to test our limits
and day-to-day life doesn't give as much
of a chance to do that that's why we
seek out these extremes there's making
zucca yes and his next him the obstacles
are based on military drills anyone who
fails to clear an obstacle has to do
burpees style push-ups the first race of
this kind the tough guy also had its
roots in army exercises it was started
by a former soldier he first sent
members of the public into the mud back
in 1987
in 2010 the tough mudder series began in
the US according to one study these
events are now more popular in the
States than marathons more than one and
a half million people have taken part
around the world electric shocks are
among the obstacles faced by the runners
in gable shmear each moment of pain
contains a kind of pleasure you have to
say it's bittersweet a kind of paradox
paradoxes and Jesus above in overcoming
these hurdles and completing the race
muffed it makes us feel happy and proud
afterwards and that's what we want to
achieve equation back at the ex let
exchange some of the obstacles are more
about teamwork than overcoming pain
owner team was about the team I wouldn't
have made it at all it's cool everyone
helps one another
the group made it together just like
they wanted to an achievement they can
all be proud of
you